Have you seen the rife heel cancer? Have you seen rife heel cancer in the bone?
Yes, for sure. Yes. So, remember, that's the beauty of the rife.
Let me step back.
If you were doing chemotherapy, let's say a person has cancer that's metastasized to their bone.
Statistically, chemotherapy is not going to work that well.
Because you do have blood supply to the bone, but it's limited.
It's hard to get healing nutrients to the bone.
Just like it's hard to get healing nutrients to the brain because you have blood brain barrier.
Well, you do have a blood supply to the bone, but it is limited, and it's difficult to get that there.
So, even chemotherapy to the bone, it's going to be difficult. That's why they would typically suggest radiation to the bone to kill the cancer, which I think can be a really good idea.
I've seen it over and over again, you see radiation to the cancer can be amazing because you could do just a few sessions.
And it can kill all the cancer in that bone. So, if a person has metastasis to the bone and it's causing issues, should be just for everybody.
But you could knock down just very quick with radiation. So, don't be dogmatic in position against radiation.
However, it's hard to get nutrients in your immune system and T cells to go and kill something in the bone.
It's where the rife is so beautiful, because the frequencies are going right through you.
So, the rife is going to go right into your brain. The rife is going to go right into your bone.
So, that's a huge, huge benefit.